i
[Música]
en méxico si bien el presidente lópez
obrador prometió no aumentar impuestos
en la primera mitad de su gobierno la
polémica surge desde el congreso con las
iniciativas de su partido morena para
incrementar el gravamen a las bebidas
azucaradas con el argumento de combatir
la epidemia de obesidad una de las
iniciativas más recientes es la del
senador salomón jara que pretende
aumentar de 1.26 a 5 pesos por litro
esto es unos 23 centavos de dólar el
sector patronal advirtió que sería el
peor momento para aumentar impuestos en
el país dada la debilidad de la economía
golpeada por la pandemia de kobe pero la
controversia se alimentó también desde
el gobierno pues el subsecretario de
salud hugo lópez gatell ha cuestionado
por qué tenemos que consumir el veneno
embotellado es decir el de los refrescos
esto le valió una dura crítica de la
asociación nacional de productores de
refresco que se quejan de que un
subsecretario satanice a una industria
que genera empleo y cumple con toda la
normatividad
[Música]
en colombia por cuarta vez en menos de
cinco años se está haciendo un intento
para ponerle un impuesto específico a
las bebidas azucaradas que tendría que
pagar el consumidor con el fin de
reducir su consumo mientras aumenta el
recaudo tributario la aspiración es
lograr un recaudo de más de 650 millones
de dólares serían directos a financiar
las necesidades del sector de la salud
fuertemente golpeado con la pandemia
este es el argumento principal con el
que se ha respaldado el proyecto de ley
que volvió a ser radicado en el congreso
un proyecto que se viene discutiendo
desde 2016 y que fue rechazado en
numerosas ocasiones por la fuerte
presión del lobby de la industria
azucarera propietaria también de algunos
medios de comunicación pese a que según
las estadísticas el 68 por ciento del
total de muertes en colombia están
relacionadas con enfermedades
cerebrovasculares y el 5 por ciento es
atribuible a las bebidas azucaradas y
cuyo gasto en diabetes atribuibles a
estos productos fue de más de 192
millones de dólares según el ministerio
de salud la organización red papaz
de que el sobrepeso constituye el 8 por
ciento del gasto social del país
[Música]
de cara a 2021 el gobierno español
pretende aumentar el iva el impuesto
sobre el valor añadido de las bebidas
azucaradas y edulcoradas univa que se
encuentra actualmente en el 10% y que
aumentaría hasta el 21% lo que en
términos de precio repercutiría en una
subida de unos 10 céntimos de euro por
cada 100 mililitros de este tipo de
bebidas sin embargo como ya ha anunciado
el propio gobierno esta medida no está
destinada a recaudar grandes sumas de
dinero sino más bien a prevenir hábitos
que puedan desencadenar en problemas de
salud pero es que precisamente esta
cuestión abre el debate sobre a quién
afecta esta subida en los impuestos
indirectos y es que precisamente el
ministerio de consumo presentaba
recientemente un informe que relacionaba
los problemas de sobrepeso y de obesidad
infantil con los hogares con menores
rentas pero es que precisamente aquí en
la comunidad de madrid' el gobierno de
derechas en la primera ola de la
pandemia cuando se cerraron las escuelas
sustituyo las becas comedor las ayudas
que reciben precisamente las familias
con menores rentas por a menos de una
conocida cadena de pizzerías
[Música]